newts and his case and the beasts coming
to New York is kind of is like the art
in into this world but the story that JK
Rowling's written and that starts in
this film is so epic in scale it's so
bigger than bigger than bees you know
over 24 hours that an unregistered
wizard set magical beasts loose in New
York yes where is this man I was away
from it for a few years and then I got
sent the script read it felt so fresh
and different and then rather than a
bridging the books Joe was going to be
writing directly for the screen that was
an interesting prospect witches live
among us discover that this world and in
JK Rowling's mind is so much more
expansive than we thought and it's
really thrilling and they're kind of
pinch me moments almost every day on set
all the great things we got to do the
interaction with the beasts of action
sequences but also I think that will
play in the most phenomenal way out yeah
lifting the shadows for too long I
refuse to bow down
the imax experience is always really
wonderful if you're wanting to drop an
audience into a very immersive narrative
experience the scene you might have
heard of where they first go into the
case which is unbelievable reveal of
places of natural beauty where these
creatures have sanctum I think will be
completely stunning imagine being
surrounded by that would be really
exciting hey mr. English guy I think
your egg is hatching for beasts I max is
just a great extension and we've done
some special individual elements of our
print for imax which break the screen
frame slightly bring bit more movie into
the audience's laughs just to sort of
make it a little bit more of an arena
experience it's a thrill it's so
exciting isn't it especially you're
gonna see it in an IMAX theater which is
gonna be so incredible and a little
powerful I don't want to see it I want
to see the rump in chasing me and I man
that would be really cool with a movie
like this you just want very loud very
large you want that Thunderbird to just
actually woo above you thrilling i mean
there's the sound and everything is so
powerful in the film and what david has
managed to mate with fantastic beasts is
a film that has that familiarity and yet
has a complete fresh take on it new era
a new country but at the same point has
those qualities that were so thoughtful
imax is just an interesting format for
particularly sequences that are fairly
spectacular it's a larger than life
experience
you